hello and welcome everyone to yet
another tech enthusiastic video from
simply learn
java is the most dominant programming
language right from its inception
yet in the current trend of artificial
intelligence machine learning
and the outbreak of big data many
beginners and professionals have a mild
dilemma
can java meet the current standards and
end up asking
give me one good reason to learn java
well
i have numerous for now i'll give you
the top 10 reasons to learn java
so that's the one shot agenda we have to
deal today
so before getting started let me tell
you guys we have daily updates on
multiple technologies
so how about you guys click on the
subscribe button and hit the bell icon
to stay updated on our technical content
so now
sit back relax and listen to all the
good reasons to get started with java
the top 10th reason is java is easy to
learn and
implement the masterpiece in the world
of object oriented programming
is continuously evolving now unlike
other programming languages
java did not make unrecognizable changes
to its fundamentals
the basic object-oriented features and
principles of java are maintained
in the same way since the beginning all
the advancements are done in the way
by introducing new libraries and apis
along with some new methods just to
reduce the time consumed in programming
java has fluent english likes and backs
with minimum characters
for example generics angle brackets
which make it easy to read a java
program and learn it quickly
once a programmer is familiar with
initial challenges like
installing jdk and setting up the path
and understand
how the class path works it's pretty
easy to write a java program
downloading and setting up java in
perfect world is really simple
don't you worry about that we got you
covered on that part
i have dropped down a link in the
description box below that will guide
you in a step-by-step manner
to successfully install java in your
local systems
so with that being said let's move on to
the top ninth reason
which says java is platform independent
the main reason that many developers and
major i.t
companies adopted java is because java
uses the principle
that says write once and run anywhere
this would have been not possible if it
did not have
jvm aka java virtual machine
so java virtual machine works in a
simple but most
effective way all the code that you
write in java programming language
is sent to the jvm before getting
executed
here the jvm converts the programmer
readable code
into bytecode and sends this bytecode to
the compiler or the interpreter
and this bytecode will be executed at
the end so this process stands the same
regardless of any environment where the
jvm is functioning in
so this makes java completely platform
independent
followed by the ninth reason we have the
top eighth reason that says
java is highly adaptable and found
everywhere
yes java is everywhere it's on the
desktop it's on the mobile it's on the
card almost
everywhere and so are the java
programmers i think java programmers
outnumber any other programming language
professionals
with ease java supports billions of
electronic devices in
real time the programming language is so
capable that it can do almost everything
from creating a functional program to
managing big data by creating crunching
tools like apache hadoop
apache spark so java is practically
everywhere it can manage the creation of
web pages designing new operating
systems like android
and much more next we have our top
seventh point that says
it has enormous community support java
programming language is the one that was
used to lay the foundation for all the
groundbreaking technologies
and frameworks that we currently use so
we have
numerous use cases code segments methods
and
what all we need to develop a new
application
apart from this we have a huge community
of java developers
right from the beginners to the
real-time experts who are
enthusiastically ready to help when
we need them some of the best examples
are stack overflow and java forums
so followed by the seventh reason we
have our top sixth reason which says
java has rich library support
open source libraries ensure that java
should be used everywhere
apache google and other organizations
have contributed a lot of
great libraries which makes development
easy
faster and cost effective in java there
are frameworks like
spring struts maven which ensures that
java development follows best practices
of software craftsmanship
promotes the use of design patterns and
assist the java developers in getting
their job done
i always recommend searching for
functionality in google
before writing your own code there is a
good chance that it's already coded and
tested
and available for ready to use next we
have our top
fifth reason that says java has proven
and powerful ides
believe it or not eclipse and netbeans
have played a huge role in making
java one of the best programming
languages for coding
coding in these ides is a real pleasure
they not only help encode completion but
also provide a powerful debugging
capability
which is essential for real-world
development integrated development
enterprise or ide
made java development much more
comfortable
faster and fluent it's easy to search
refactor and read code using ides
apart from ide the java platform also
has
several other tools like maven and and
for building java applications
jenkins for continuous integration and
delivery
decompilers j console visual vm
for monitoring heap usage etc
so with this we enter into our top
fourth reason
that says java has generous or rich
api support the major reason for the
java programming language
huge success is its capability to adopt
the user's requirements
and this is achieved by the java through
its api or the application programming
interface the java api support comes
along during the installation of
java java provides api for almost
everything to name a few it supports
input output networking utilities
xml passing database connection and
almost
everything whatever left is covered by
open source
libraries like apache commons google
guava
and many more followed by that we have
our top
third reason which says java supports
big data
artificial intelligence and machine
learning yes
artificial intelligence and machine
learning many have a misconception that
python is for data science and java is
not built for that
i mean really all you're doing is making
a machine
learning to keep it simple java
incorporates the right tools and
libraries that are required to execute
ai and machine learning based algorithms
and programs now coming into big data
the foundation of big data
and its frameworks was laid by using the
java programming language
so it has a greater support for both
machine learning artificial intelligence
and big data so followed by the top
third reason we have our top second
reason
which says java is a highly demanded
programming language
programmers with a sound knowledge of
java are in great demand
with a large installed base this widely
used programming language continues to
create jobs in
every tech industry additionally the
popularity of
android apps has brought along countless
opportunities
for an android developer who writes
native apps in java
being a mature programming language
there are numerous resources
available online that can act as your
perfect companion
in the learning process depending upon
your need you can look for free and paid
sources
for learning and aid yourself in short
almost any imaginable doubt related to
java has been already been
asked and answered on the online forums
and according to the chat on my screen
you can see
java is one of the most sorted
programming languages
for development purposes and finally we
enter the topmost reason to learn
java it is the high salary packages
java developers are amongst the highest
paid it employs in the current iit
industry
having said that we shall now discuss
the salary trends of java developers in
america
and india so first
we will discuss the average salary
packages of java developers in the
united states of america
so for an entry-level java developer
america offers
60 000 us dollars and for an experienced
java developer
the salary packages are nearly 1 lakh 20
000 and also above this information is
provided by the popular website
glasto so followed by the united states
of america
now we shall discuss the salary trends
of a java developer in
india
so in india for an entry level java
developer the salary might start from 4
lakh 50 000 rupees
and for an experienced java developer
the salary packages
can start from 10 lakhs and also it
might reach to
a higher number based on your experience
and performance
so with this we have come to an end of
this discussion if you have any queries
related to this topic
then please feel free to reach us out
you can drop your queries
in the comment section below and we will
have them answered from our experts team
as early as possible
this is ravi signing off thank you until
next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here